all right Tim is with us in Nashville
hey Tim how are you great Dave good
great to speak with you you too sir
all right so what is your net worth it's
actually 1.25 million gotcha
cool and what is that invest it in give
me a little break down here okay we've
got 500,000 in retirement savings row 3b
rollover IRAs and that's invested in
what mutual funds that's in mutual funds
okay and then we've got 305 in taxable
investments mostly stocks
and a little bit of mutual funds not you
now to 250,000 of that was just
inherited okay so and then we've got
you're already a millionaire before you
got an inheritance okay yes we were and
then we've got $100,000 paid for rental
condo mm-hmm
110,000 dollars in cash mm-hmm and call
it a hundred and thirty thousand for a
paid-for house very good all right good
mix very cool all right how old are you
I am 64 and my wife is much younger ah I
got you okay
smart man that you are all right mine's
actually older than me but she's much
younger than me so there you go
slightly so income average work through
your working lifetime we over the last
ten years it's been about 70,000 okay
yeah we did have a high one year of a
hundred and thirty thousand
mm-hm and that was the year my my wife
decided that she was she'd had it and
she's been staying home for the last
eight years gotcha
okay cool and so your career choice I am
an accountant okay all right so I assume
you have a degree in accounting I have a
degree in accounting with a 3.3 GPA okay
and that was not on the four-year plan
it took much longer okay and during the
time that you're building this wealth
how much money did you borrow in order
to invest in other words how much of the
wealth was caused by borrowed money well
to be honest there was about a negative
65
and that that is listed in your stupid
tax stories about eight or ten years ago
all right so no -60 all right and I
would have been calling a year ago area
all right
so what part philosophically
theologically does giving play in your
financial plan it's a big part we leave
tithe to our church ten percent right
off the top and then we have other
charities that we selectively contribute
to during the year at the time I do our
taxes every year and see what our
contributions we're we're always a
little surprised and pleased and you've
done that throughout your working
lifetime yes okay so your most expensive
pair of jeans about thirty okay cool how
many new cars did you buy before you are
a millionaire well I bought one in
nineteen nineteen eighty seven and
quickly knew that that was a big mistake
Wow but we buy high quality used cars
known for the longevity Carl new car is
fourteen years old and has a hundred and
fifty thousand miles on it
Wow well you're a great American Hero
thanks for sharing your story brother
very good stuff another millionaire on
the millionaire theme hour hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that your broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you